[Music]
we are back again the ps+ offerings for
June 2020 are now fully revealed so
let's add to yesterday's unveiling of
Call of Duty World War 2 which is also
available to download right now
whereas this new game we have to wait
until Tuesday the 2nd of June okay with
housekeeping out of the way let's do
this it's Star Wars Battlefront - an
action based first and third person
shooter with lightsaber wielding
shenanigans for good measure and both
single and multiplayer modes to suit
everyone the solo portion is for you
Star Wars fans out there who want to
learn more about the universe focusing
on filling the gap in time between
Return of the Jedi and the force awakens
we play as AI Denver CO an imperial
special forces commander so effectively
one of the bad guys the big question is
will she stay that way you'll have to
play to find out there's also a new
Droid ID 10 whoa look at his face the
multiplayer side of battlefront 2 is
likely where you'll spend most of your
time at last count there were 12 game
modes ranging from galactic assaults
based around different scenarios from
Star Wars films in a 20 on 20 attack
versus defense scenario but there's also
more casual modes like II walk hunt
where two Ewoks hunt down 18
stormtroopers yeah that's a real thing
okay let's get one issue though in the
open back when Battlefront 2 first
released it had a pretty serious issue
in the shape of loot boxes which gave
substantial in-game advantages over
other players so yeah it had pay2win
elements those were removed a few months
later and the community began to love
battlefront 2 leading to many outlets
like IGN re reviewing the game awarding
it a higher score in the end it was an 8
point 8 out of 10 Star Wars Battlefront
2 received its final update in April
this year as the devs move on to another
project meaning this is the most full
the most complete version of the game
that will ever exist definitely worth a
download in my eyes when battlefront
released back in 2017 it only was
outsold by one game Call of Duty World
War 2 a segue if you watched yesterday
you already know that that's the second
game for a month and it's already
downloadable right
now and for those who were asking it
includes the zombie mode a compelling
story based around real-life events and
the multiplayer modes are here with
authentic weaponry from that time period
I'll link yesterday's video at the end
of this so I don't waste more of your
time now I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade are you happier with this
month's offerings I'll be stocking in
the comments to find out thanks for
stopping by see you soon
[Music]